democrats and their allies in big
tech have become incredibly hostile
toward roughly half the country now
after years of peaceful trump rallies
and
early tea party events they were all
peaceful the january 6
capital riot was a gift to democrats
it gave them the video and the narrative
that they've desperately wanted and they
needed to justify a crackdown
on the civil liberties of all
conservatives
and it's coming from the highest levels
of the biden administration
starting at the doj biden's attorney
general pick merrick garland believes
that january 6
was worse than the oklahoma city bombing
that killed more than 160 americans
including children we are facing a more
dangerous period than we faced in
oklahoma city
i intend to give the career prosecutors
who
are working on this matter 24 7
all the resources they could possibly
require i intend
to to make sure that we look more
broadly
to look at where this is coming from
what other groups there might be that
that could raise the same problem in the
future
and i know that fbi director has made
the same commitment
okay what does judge garland mean by
quote looking more broadly
is that more domestic surveillance lower
probable cause standards for wiretaps
this sounds like the patriot act on
steroids
democrats used to oppose gross
government overreach like this but
on capitol hill today they were
embracing it
domestic terrorism is not a new threat
but it is an
urgent threat it will require serious
focus to ensure that we are doing
everything we
can to protect the safety and security
of
all americans every senator here today
took an oath to protect and defend the
constitution against all enemies both
foreign
and domestic well today's hearing is our
first on january 6
attack it will not be our last
now by the way these same senators who
wax on about preventing domestic
terrorism
they have zero problem as far as i can
tell with antifa have you ever heard him
even speak about antifa
they also have no qualms with biden's
gutting
of our border enforcement making it a
cinch for terrorists to enter america
and for illegal alien criminals of
course to avoid deportation
does that affect our safety senator now
what democrats are pushing
of course isn't about your security it's
about criminalizing
an entire political movement in america
you don't need hearings to know that
dedicated men and women of the capitol
police
were overwhelmed and unprepared for a
breach
by your your intelligence folks on
january 3rd
the intelligence division of the capitol
police issued a
internal report which reportedly stated
the proud boys white supremacist groups
other extremist groups would be in
attendance and quote again out in public
sources
may be inclined to become violent so you
you have your own
report did you see that report that was
put out on the third
yes i did but how was that that not a
real big warning flag and if it was what
exactly did you do when you read that
report
unreal they had the report but the
solution offered for preventing
future breaches of the capital is
surveillance of more americans
i think my big concern is you know on
the on the collection
on how wide we're casting the net
collect to collect our intelligence that
would have revealed
this was coming and we were facing this
type of mass insurrection
first of all anyone who has studied
armed insurrections throughout history
knows that this one was pretty lame by
comparison it was a riot it was
despicable
criminal and infuriating but a riot
the only person shot inside the capital
was an unarmed air force vet
named ashley babbitt and i don't think
we still know
who the officer was who shot her or the
circumstances surrounding why he did it
now we still haven't seen the
after-action report on her death
are we interested in that the loss of
life that occurred that day
is still shrouded in mystery now from
the get-go
the media saw this tragic day as an
opportunity to tar the entire trump
coalition
as a bunch of heinous terrorists false
reports remember circulated for weeks
claiming that trump supporters smashed
officer brian sicknick over the head
with a fire extinguisher killing him
but now that is even called into
question
now how can this be we still don't know
anything about
officer sicknick's cause of death but we
know the entire life story of the idiot
in the buffalo getup and face paint
you get the gist well too bad if you
voted for trump
if you ever intended a trump rally or
posted support for his america first
agenda
you're complicit you're complicit in the
attack
and you need to be shunned from society
lose your job
and you need to be banned from social
media indefinitely
with the assistance of their benefactors
in big tech
the democrats are working overtime to
frighten
good patriotic americans from exercising
their freedoms
they want to make you fearful of
speaking out of sharing your views
online
of attending peacefully attending
rallies
and it all begins to feel like a police
state environment heck it
in washington it already is look at what
we've come to
these military vehicles and razor wire
are here for one reason
and one reason only because pelosi and
company
they want you to think that pro-trump
insurrectionists
are plotting right at this very moment
maybe in idaho somewhere
to overthrow congress oh they know
that's not true it's a total lie
a few senators though they do see how
this could all backfire for the
democrats
how do we protect the capital from
either of
an angry mob or probably more likely
one or two or three malignant of
actors without turning it into a
fortress i think there are options
for maintaining a an open environment an
open campus type of environment
while putting some substantial physical
security
uh measures in place both for the
building the skin of the building
as well as farther out you know time and
distance is our best friend
now this is absurd they want to keep
american citizens
from having the freedom to walk around
capitol hill to assemble peacefully near
the representatives
who work for us on january 6 we had a
problem with
what about 800 people out of a country
of 330 million
but we're a free people we're free to
speak out
we're free to petition the government
we're free to assemble to travel and
worship
make no mistake about it what we're
witnessing at all levels of society run
by liberals
is a new red scare but instead of
targeting marxists or communists
they're fighting americans in red states
and this entire entire charade on
capitol hill
is designed to forbid the maga people
from assembling
so no more maga rallies no more
organizing your boat parades online
that's all domestic terrorism now they
might not be able to use covid to keep
you home
so now they've come up with a far more
reaching menace
scare tactics and thuggery are all the
democrats have
the states they run are teetering on the
edge let's face it new york is failing
california that's failing illinois is a
total mess
michigan isn't far behind new england
where i'm from
it's hollowing out it's lost its
manufacturing base it's drowning in high
taxes
but just like their coveted lockdowns
democrat efforts to criminalize
the america first movement it's going to
crash and burn
these attempts to limit the free speech
and assembly of citizens
are going to run into the buzzsaw of
those 200 federal judges appointed by
donald trump
and soon this is also going to happen
the weather it's going to get better
and when it does all those left-wing
protests are going to return
and then once again we'll see what a
bunch of frauds
the democrats really are suddenly all
the liberal concerns about domestic
terrorism and violence
it's just going to fade away just like
their political futures
and that's the angle